go ahead hello welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology q a
for kids and others so they were
starting a little late today
um
Let's see we have a number of questions
here
um
uh gosh
the question here
about
[Music]
um
I'm trying to remember which things I've
discussed um
uh in the past there's a question here
about how do we predict the weather
let's let's talk about that a little bit
I think I have talked about this uh one
time before but let's let's talk about
it now
so
the uh in the past there were a couple
of different approaches to predicting
the weather and
um uh the the sort of the question of
whether you make a physical model of the
circulation of air in the atmosphere
there are typically the what's important
is both the way that the winds stack up
and where the winds go and also the
humidity and the question of where
clouds form and it's always been a a
challenging question to predict where
there are going to be clouds and more to
the point where those clouds are
actually going to produce rain and it's
always a complicated thing because
eventually clouds are water vapor and
they're they're at the there are
situations in which the droplets of
water vapor that in which the water
vapor starts condensing into droplets
the droplets get bigger and bigger there
comes a critical point at which droplets
are colliding with each other to make
bigger droplets eventually those
droplets are heavy enough that the winds
that push upwards no longer keep them
Aloft and they start falling and that's
when you get rain and predicting when
that's going to happen is often quite
challenging I think the um
the thing that uh used to be true
maybe 40 50 years ago is that people
will try and predict the weather by
looking at large-scale features of the
circulation of air high pressure areas
low pressure areas these kinds of things
and you would see these weather charts
that would have you know high pressure
Zone here low pressure Zone there are
fronts between them and so on and people
kind of got pretty good at saying well
if there's a front here and there's a
low pressure Zone there and there's a
high pressure Zone here this is at that
kind of large-scale level this is what's
likely to happen with the weather and
there are some parts of the world where
that worked pretty well where there
weren't lots of mountains and coastlines
and things like that in the picture and
other places where there were lots of
things that kind of made it hard to just
look at these large-scale features and
predict what would happen actually the
very first computerized weather
prediction was started in 1950 very
early and people assumed at that time
that was uh John Von Neiman in a chap
called Charney
um and uh they assumed at first oh now
that we've got computers to work out the
equations for what will happen if you
have just little tiny packets of air and
you just compute what happens as that
air flows around they thought it's going
to be easy now that we have computers to
do this to predict everything about the
weather turned out not to be true
and why wasn't it true well we all got a
bit confused because in the early 1960s
a chap called adlerance was a
meteorologist at MIT I knew him somewhat
actually
um the uh
made an interesting observation which
was that if you simplify the equations
of the weather
um but technically you did a modal
truncation which kind of assumed that
there wasn't friction in the air that
there wasn't viscosity in the air and
you just looked at sort of the the
lowest in his particular case three sort
of modes of motion in the air where you
had different kinds of circulation and
so on you just looked at that simplified
case you got a mathematical equation a
differential equation which had the
property that if you just made a very
tiny change in the initial data that you
gave to the equation you would quite you
would sort of the the trajectories that
you would get for what the weather would
do with diverge Expo financially and so
that was an observation they've been
seen in a whole bunch of other
mathematical systems
um hadn't really been noted that
strongly this idea that a small change
in at one point can amplify
progressively into a larger change later
on I mean a very simple case where that
happens if you have two spheres two
spherical balls you you bounce them off
each other if they hit right on axis
they'll just bounce back the way they
came but if they hit even slightly off
axis they will they'll just by the
geometry of it they'll bounce back sort
of let's say twice as far away from the
axis as they originally were and that
will get Amplified at every Progressive
bounce they'll be they'll be like twice
as far away from the axes as they were
before so that as you go for a few
bounces you'll get you'll get it'll be
you know two four eight sixteen Etc et
cetera et cetera it will increase
exponentially what the distance is and
so what at Lawrence found was that in
these particular equations that are
approximated this very dramatic
approximation to the weather that really
wasn't an accurate representation of how
the atmosphere and the weather really
works but in that dramatic
simplification
um it was the case that if you made just
a tiny numerical change to the
parameters to the to the values of let's
say the uh something like a velocity at
the beginning then you would get this
exponential increase of effect and so
this was sort of one of the things that
was the origin of kind of this idea of
chaos theory and the idea of sensitive
Independence on initial conditions and
the idea of the sort of exponential
growth of dependence on initial
conditions and it kind of led to this
notion of you know well if a butterfly
flaps its wings in one place that might
lead to a hurricane somewhere because in
one if the butterfly did flap its wings
the hurricane is produced if it didn't
flap its wings there is a eventually
huge change in in what the weather is
like and there won't be a hurricane
okay this picture is really not correct
this picture is very specific to
particular mathematical approximations
that were made it is the case that the
butterfly happens to be in exactly the
right place at the right time then yes
it can matter which way it flapped its
wings but the chance of the butterfly
being in exactly the right place at the
right time is absolutely infinitesimally
small and most of the time most
Butterfly Effects sorry for the
butterfly just won't have any
substantial consequence for history it's
you know most most things that happen in
the history of the atmosphere won't
really have much effect it's only the
very rare one that's right on the knife
edge between this and that where you can
have that big effect and it so happens
that in the case of adlerances equations
that that was something that that very
much got Amplified that effect was very
much sort of a an everywhere effect as
opposed to being an effect where most of
the time nothing really happens because
most of the time it's like imagine and
you've got some water for example and
you you stir up some of the water well
most of the time the stirring that you
do will just die out
occasionally if you let's say you've got
some water where you can it can either
slosh out of your you've got it in some
cup or something and you're stirring it
around and occasionally if you uh you
know you're slushing it around just such
a way that it might go over the edge and
then if it's just about on sort of a
knife edge is it going to go over the
edge or is it not well then a detail of
how you stir it can affect whether it
goes over the edge or doesn't but most
of the time most of that stirring you
make it will just die down and
eventually your your you know hot
chocolate or whatever it is will be will
be flat again
so
in any case the the um uh this this led
to kind of the assumption that the the
sort of the the problem of predicting
the weather was really getting accurate
values for you know measuring all these
different kinds of um uh things about
the temperature of the air and so on and
that that is important but it isn't uh
it doesn't have quite that same sort of
exponential growth and effect that one
might think from that mathematical
simplification what's more to the point
is that it can matter uh what you know
for example the the swirl of the air
over the top of a mountain can matter it
can cause a cloud to form or something
like this
um it's it's and the fact is that the
difference in Scales between sort of
what happens around the peak of that
mountain and what happens over a large
land area of a Thousand Miles uh it can
matter what the detail of where the
mountain was
um is and that means when you're doing a
numerical calculation or you're trying
to sort of divide the Earth up into
zones and you're trying to say we're
just going to deal with the air in this
region we're just going to deal with the
air in this region you can end up with
places where you have to have very fine
gradation where you have to have very
detailed uh calculation and that means
it can be just a difficult thing in
terms of of doing the computation to
work out what what happens particularly
true I mean I forget what the what the
actual numbers are these days but you
know it's like maybe there are 10 layers
or something of air that people consider
and maybe the Earth is divided into you
know uh squares of of maybe 20 mile
um uh 20 miles across or something
that's not quite enough if you have you
know the mountain peak can affect things
and that's smaller than that
um so what tends to happen is that
because there are things that are quite
you know small relative to the size of
the Earth that can affect whether that
causes trouble now you know there are
things that people have done
to try and improve predictability I
think one of the more one of the more
obvious ones in recent times that was
started by a series of apps maybe 10
years ago or so now was the following
rather simple idea so there's weather
radar so weather radar is looking for
water drops of a certain size
um certain range of sizes that reflect
radar reflect radio energy uh of a
particular frequency they reflect it
well and so that means you can have a
radar dish that's that's going around
and sending out radio pulses in all
different directions and in some
directions those radio pulses will get
reflected back by
um by the uh water drops and so you can
map out you know where is the uh where's
some
uh where are the where the water drops
and then there's Doppler radar where
you're actually looking at the effect
when when the water drop is moving
um as a result of the wind you're you're
looking at the change of frequency when
the when the radio you send out radio of
a certain frequency and when it hits
something that's moving the frequency of
the thing that comes back will be
slightly affected by the by the motion
of the the object and so you can map out
sort of wind and and the amount of uh of
uh of of drops in the air and then
people had the idea well gosh if we can
see the which way the wind is going and
we can kind of um uh and we know you
know kind of what the structure of the
clouds is and so on we can just use uh
pretty straightforward
kind of take that structure of cloud and
assume that it's going to move more or
less the same for a while
um and see what happens I think people
tried to improve that with machine
learning and and probably got some
reasonable results along those lines you
know when weather forecasting is done in
one of the things that happens is that
because one doesn't know the exact data
everywhere one has to say well what
happens if the if the data was slightly
we know these particular places but we
don't know in between those places what
the data is let's make different
assumptions between those places and
let's make let's see what the forecast
does if we look at what happens in the
future with different assumptions about
what the temperature of or wind speed is
in some particular place and I think
what's usually done is people make I
don't know a dozen different forecasts
based on those different assumptions and
then the question is you look at those
forecasts and one forecast says it's
going to rain another forecast it's
going to say it's going to be nice you
know sunshine or whatever
um and then the question is what do you
how do you aggregate together those
forecasts and for example you can say
well there's an X percent chance of rain
because out of those dozen forecasts
five of them said it was raining and
seven of them said it wasn't raining
um and so that's one way to get
probabilities it's a little tricky
because what you you sort of you don't
what you don't know you really don't
know and so to say well actually there
is some definite thing that's going to
happen and the you know we had to fill
in this data that we didn't know and we
we didn't know it so we didn't know it
and therefore we didn't know how to fill
it in and so this question of sort of
how much weight should you put on the
different possible ways to fill in that
data it's very hard to work out and what
what tended to be the case I'm not sure
if this is still true but it tended to
be the case that the forecasts that were
done by for example US Government
um uh
um tended to have uh tended to look for
extreme cases and this Ensemble and this
collection different forecasts tended to
look for the extreme cases because
that's important if you're routing
planes around or you're trying to give
Farmers advice or whatever else it can
be important what the extreme or you're
trying to work out is there going to be
a hurricane that forms it can be
important what the extreme cases are if
you just want to know what's it most
likely to do is it most likely to rain
or not today
um then it's uh those extreme cases
aren't really such an important thing
but it certainly used to be the case
that uh people would just take those
government forecasts and compute
probabilities from uh from those things
which have been actually worked out for
the purposes of having extreme cases I
think probably now more people are
running these weather models I know we
looked at running these weather models
for from alpha a decade ago decided not
to
um although it certainly it was within
the realm of possibility to do do it it
was kind of a bit of a super computer
Adventure but not too much of one the
the thing that um uh and you know we did
look at the question of whether if you
look to the forecasts that have been
made and you looked at what actually
happened to the weather which way did
the errors go because you might imagine
you could use some kind of machine
learning Loop to say oh we we did
weather prediction and the weather
prediction came out wrong in some way
relative to what the weather actually
did let's use machine learning to to
improve that at least at that time it
was interesting that the the errors
associated with the the of the actual
weather relative to the predicted
weather were very uh normal distributed
they were very there was no obvious
signal there was no obvious regularity
to there's no obvious thing you can kind
of latch onto and say let's make a model
of the way in which the weather
forecasts are wrong so it wasn't it
wasn't easy to see how to improve how to
just sort of use machine learning to
improve that I have to say that one one
looks at the successes of machine
learning in all sorts of different areas
whether it's in language generation in
recent weeks or whether it's in protein
folding or whether it's in different
kinds of places an interesting question
is whether whether forecasting is one of
these places where one should expect
that you know machine learning is going
to win the day
rather than actually solving the
equations for uh for the motion of of of
of uh of air and so on I don't know the
answer to that I think there are certain
cases in which you cannot expect that
machine learning will win the day
because what happens in machine learning
is you'll really just trying to you
really have a lot of data and you're
trying to say the thing that you see now
how does it relate to data that you've
seen before and kind of the
transformation from what you see now to
what you've seen before that machine
learning kind of allows you is not that
great a transformation it's kind of not
like it can figure out things that
require a huge depth of calculation to
work out it's just like well it's pretty
similar to that thing I've seen before
so let me do this now and that's how it
works for you know in the protein
folding case once first you know the
first step is just to compare the new
protein that you're being shown with all
the proteins that have are known in
databases and and then you kind of sort
of try and arrange sort of knits
together the things that you get where
you say I've seen one like this before
and it came out this way and so on
so it is interesting that the sort of
old-fashioned way of doing weather
forecasting which was you know when I
see a cold front and of this and that
together then this is what's going to
happen is much more similar to what you
might expect that machine learning would
now do but perhaps do on a more
industrial scale rather than the thing
that one does in sort of traditional
computer weather forecasting but one
sort of accurately trying to predict
this you know this this little region of
air that's at this layer in in this
geographic location on the Earth is
going to move in this way
so I it's an interesting question I
don't know the answer
um what uh whether this is a place where
one can expect that um
that the that um uh
um that machine learning will be
successful
um but uh yeah so that's a little bit on
on weather forecasting and I think the
main issue is people say you know it's
the it's the one day forecast it's the
five-day forecast it's the whatever and
uh what happens is uh people kind of
have had this idea that oh this is going
to be this exponential Divergence
because that's what one saw in Chaos
Theory I don't think that's the usual
picture I think the Divergence is much
less than that
um and what's gradually happened as
there are sort of more accurate and more
detailed models for uh for actual you
know the atmosphere one's able to make
longer and longer range predictions
um on the order of you know week two
week type predictions I think at the at
the outside for what's going to happen
uh in the atmosphere and it can be
different in different places there are
parts of the world uh where it's more
difficult got to predict the weather
than others they're places where it's a
very uniform giant sort of plane in the
middle of a continent and the weather
just rolls across it without much change
and there are places where lots of
mountains and other topography or lots
of coastlines where there are lots of
changes
I think you know a question people ask
is is okay well we can predict the
weather week two weeks out you know
what's going to happen to the global
climate of the earth you know a century
from now that's a very different problem
very much more the kinds of calculations
that you can do that are really just
taking the detail of of the motion of
air and so on and Computing it forwards
are that's something where you can sort
of expect to have some accurate results
when you have to when you're trying to
predict kind of the the the long-range
climate it's a much different kind of
calculation uh fraught with difficulties
I think last I knew clouds were one of
the biggest too just how many clouds are
there going to be and what effect are
they going to have and they're just an
awkward thing to deal with because why
where you can in the case of sort of the
you can imagine you're dividing the the
atmosphere up into these regions of
height and and position and latitude
longitude that's all well and good but
if one place has a cloud and the other
one doesn't then you can have very
different effects there and that you
know the the where the cloud is or isn't
um is something that sort of cuts across
all the little little squares that you
might have had that represent different
regions of the Earth
well let's see
um
yes Paul is commenting basically weather
forecasting is an excellent example of
computational irreducibility yes it is
and and I could perhaps have said
something about that the um this whole
question of of when you know the sort of
the rules of fluid flow there are
equations the navierstopes equations
from the 1830s or so I think that um
tell you given that you have a certain
pressure and you have a certain velocity
of a fluid how will that velocity change
through time we know the equations for
that yet just knowing the equations
doesn't immediately tell us so what's
going to happen
we know we can work that out in
principle uh by
running a computer and and just doing
the calculations Well normally we know
that unfortunately for fluid equations
the fluid equations are Continuum
equations which means that they describe
infinitesimally what the velocity is of
a fluid at a very specific point you go
a tiny distance away they'll say it's a
different velocity they say the velocity
changes only slowly with position that's
and that's kind of it's that slow change
the fact that you can always look at the
the the slope of the change and things
like this that's what means it allows
you to kind of pull calculus into the
picture and allows you to have these
differential equations that you can work
on so it um uh but the the issue with
that is when you try and make a computer
deal with those kinds of things
computers don't deal with arbitrarily
fine sort of Continuum stuff they don't
you just have to say there's this number
there's these bits there's those bits
you don't get to say there's this
continuous variation of velocity with
position you have to discretize it in
some way and it's always a challenge
with something like the navi Stokes
equations to know whether you can
whether the discretization you're using
is actually going to work correctly one
of the challenges with those equations
is that there are these phenomena like
fluid turbulence that sort of Randomness
you get in fast flowing fluids and
nobody's really been able to reproduce
that well from the underlying equations
directly
um because it's always been unclear
whether the reason you're seeing kind of
Randomness when you solve these
equations is because something went
wrong with the way you put the equations
on a computer or whether it's a genuine
feature of the equations themselves it's
a long run challenging problem to work
out sort of even very basic features of
the solutions to the official fluid
dynamics equations and we don't even
know whether whether all the phenomena
that we see in fluids can be captured by
the official fluid dynamics equations
because those official equations
describe a fluid as a continuous thing
they ignore the fact that the fluid is
at the at the lowest level made of
molecules I mean we have a very
analogous thing in the equations of
space-time the Einstein equations which
are also these differential equations
that describe sort of a continuous uh uh
version of of what the structure of
space and time are and there's we know
that the Einstein equations form
singularities
um in black holes and things like this
where the equations themselves say these
equations are not valid here because
they're they're saying even though the
equations are all about smooth variation
of in that case the curvature of space
as a function of position the the
equations are same saying no no actually
there's a place where the curvature
space varies infinitely quickly so sort
of by by set up these equations can't be
valid now in the case of of space-time
we haven't known for sure whether space
time really is governed by Continuum
equations
um or whether in fact like a fluid it
actually has something discrete
underneath I've I've believed for quite
a while that there's something discrete
underneath and in fact our physics
project from the last three years has
given I think really very good evidence
that there's something discrete
underneath space just as there's
something discrete underneath kind of
the uh the the structure of fluids in
the case of fluids it's molecules in the
case of space it's what one can sort of
call atoms of space but they're really
they're really kind of abstract entities
that are part of these giant hypographs
that we think make up the structure of
the microscopic structure of space
and uh the the thing that um
one sees in in these situations as in in
the case of fluids is you know you're
trying to solve the equations well on a
computer you have to make them discreet
and the discreetness you get on a
computer is much coarser than the
discreetness that you get when dealing
with actual molecules a lot more
molecules in a very small region of of
water or air or whatever than you can
ever model on a current on a present day
computer and then you have to make all
kinds of uh fancy Arguments for why the
very much coarse discreetness that you
have on a computer is good enough
actually it's turning out that the kind
of discreetness that we get in our
models of of physics and space-time and
so on look like they might actually be
helpful for understanding the ways that
you make discreetness for things like
fluids as well
um and and also for there are many other
situations where you have this kind of
Continuum description for example when
you have a um a solid and you're bending
that solid there are the equations of
elasticity which um also are these same
kinds of Continuum differential
equations and again it looks like our
the ideas from our physics project might
give one a better way to discretize
those equations visions
let's see
well
there's some
oh my
all sorts of questions here so I've just
been um
all right I'll talk about uh
I I've just sort of more or less
finished
a um project that I started 50 years ago
to understand uh the second law of
thermodynamics
so maybe I'll uh just in the process of
posting this uh rather giant collection
of uh of pieces
um the last one should go out today uh
about the how the second row of
thermodynamics works so maybe I'll talk
a little bit about that here
so
okay what is thermodynamics
thermodynamics is the theory of the
Dynamics of heat what
how does heat work
in in and and how does heat flow from
one place to another
well the first thing that there are
there are sort of four laws of
thermodynamics that people talk about a
lot
um they were all kind of developed in
the mid-1800s
um but the first law of thermodynamics
is
essentially the law of the conservation
of energy
and people hadn't known what heat was
and people had had the idea of energy as
being associated with mechanical motion
of things that there's a certain amount
of energy we know about for example
kinetic energy something of a certain
Mass moves at a certain speed in
standard classical physics it's just a
formula that says the kinetic energy is
a half MV squared and that's the that's
the amount of energy associated with the
motion of something so there are
different forms of energy there are uh
you know things like chemical energy or
nuclear energy or there's also thermal
energy
and the thing that was sort of a a
surprise in a sense in the mid-1800s was
this idea that heat is also a form of
energy and that when you uh when you
heat things up that that you put energy
into something when you heat it up and
that energy in the form of heat is also
it's sort of interchangeable with energy
that is mechanical energy
um and so the first law of
thermodynamics just says basically total
energy is conserved energy associated
with mechanical motion energy associated
with heat they can trade off against
each other but the the total of that
energy is conserved
as a question I think here about what
energy actually is
um
well let's see at what level to answer
that question
the first thing to say is energy is a
number
for every every thing
can be said to have a certain energy
associated with it and you can kind of
say that that that closed box that you
might have the total energy just some
number is always conserved if nothing
flows into or out of the box
then the total energy inside that box is
conserved it's a it's a single number
that's conserved it might not be a
single number it might be that energy
was a collection of five numbers that
were calculated in some complicated way
but it isn't it's one number that is a a
single quantity associated with stuff
inside a box a little bit of a footnote
when you get up to cosmological scales
and you're dealing with the large-scale
structure of the universe and so on the
whole idea of energy conservation
doesn't really work quite the same way
anymore because of things to do with the
expansion of the universe and so on but
for small scale things
what you have in that closed isolated
box the total energy is conserved
now
that's to say that you can look at all
these different things in that box and
you can say I'm going to assign this
number and that number whenever whatever
happens in that box that number is
always going to be conserved now if you
say what really is energy what uh you
know is there can you drill down and say
what's making that thing that is called
Energy I think we now know that as a
result of our physics project but you
have to go many many levels down from
the kind of experience of energy that we
normally have in just kinetic energy of
things moving around or chemical energy
or or you know energy and chemical
reactions or whatever else
um what um
uh what energy I think ultimately is is
the following thing and I'm surprised
there's such a simple interpretation but
I think there is so in our models of
physics everything in the universe is
made of this giant Network so all there
is is these these elements these atoms
of space these Eames as we sometimes
call them that are just discrete things
whose only attribute is that they are
they exist and they're different from
other such things so there's just this
whole kind of dust of Eames of atoms of
space that are the sort of raw material
of the universe and the only thing we
know about these atoms of space is how
they're related to other atoms of space
or we can say well let's make a network
let's say which atom of space is friends
with which other atom of space and we
make this network that indicates that
sort of friend network of the atoms of
space
and that's it for how the universe is
built and all of the features of the
universe whether it's the structure of
space on a large scale whether it's the
presence of an electron all these kinds
of things they're all just features of
this network of of connections between
atoms of space
so it's a very very clean kind of uh
ultimate representation of what the
universe is made of it's just made of
these atoms of space and it's related by
these connections between them and so
everything that is a thing we experience
has to be a feature of that Network so
it's you know the analogy that one can
use is you know in a fluid there's all
these molecules bouncing around but
there are features that we might notice
like that Vortex that's moving through
the fluid that's how we think electrons
and all these other features of of our
universe work they're just features of
this giant network of space okay so in
that picture what is energy I think it's
actually really simple energy is
essentially the amount of activity in
the network so at every moment the
network is getting reckoned it has
certain rules that say if you see a
little piece of network that looks like
this rewrite it into one that looks like
that and energy seems to just be the
density of rewriting that happens in the
network so for example and we can kind
of Trace through the presence of energy
causes curvature in space which is the
origin of gravity and all sorts of other
things like that but in the end what is
energy energy is the density of activity
of rewrites in the network of that
represents space but that's at a very
low level maybe you know some trillion
trillion trillion trillion trillion from
a meter scale size relative to to the
normal things we see okay so anyway the
first law of thermodynamics just says
energy is conserved energy associated
with uh
um with large-scale mechanical motions
energy so it's a bit heat now a thing
that only became clear kind of in the
late 1800s was what heat is people sort
of thought that heat was like a fluid
that would just sort of seep into
materials and things what people
eventually realized is that the heat as
we normally experience it is associated
with microscopic motion molecules so
there's you know when we say when we're
making a thing hot what it means that
it's hot is that the individual
molecules are sort of randomly running
around faster and faster and the the
speed that they're running around the
average speed they're running around is
what we call the temperature of the
object
uh is related by some constant to what
we call the temperature of the object
so
the uh uh that so the the first law of
thermodynamics is just saying all that
random running around of those molecules
versus the large-scale motion of all the
molecules coherently moving in a certain
direction all those kinds of things are
just interchangeable with each other
they all just add up and make uh
conserve total energy
okay what's the second law about the
second law says there's this
irreversible process whereby large-scale
mechanical motion turns into heat but it
doesn't go in reverse
so
roughly the you know if you do the sort
of the very early experiment uh late
1700s was uh boring out a um a cannon
people don't do this so much anymore you
know from out of iron I suppose you're
you're you know you're boring it so that
you're making this hole for the cannon
um and the point is that the mechanical
motion that you're doing uh there's then
friction and the result of that
mechanical motion as it gets turned into
heat and that means that the large-scale
mechanical motion of this boring the
Canon out is is ends up being something
which contributes its energy its energy
but the total energy is conserved but
the energy associated with the the you
know boring of the Canon ends up being
little microscopic energy associated
with the these individual molecules
running around and making this thing we
call Heat
a very famous paper by a guy called
klausius who was one of The Originators
of thermodynamics
um that's called it's in German but it's
it's um uh its title is the kind of
motion we call Heat
and he was sort of making the points
that heat is a form of motion it's just
this microscopic motion of molecules and
the real point is it's very disorganized
motion you know you take this giant
thing that's boring out the Canon the
Canon
uh the thing for the Canon
um and uh it's all as you as you turn
that boring thing every atom in that
thing you're turning is moving together
whereas when it's turned into heat all
the atoms and the thing that got hot are
just running around randomly
okay so the second or thermodynamics
basically says that there is a sort of
irreversible tendency to go from the the
uh
uh this kind of organized motion to
disorganize motion to heat
um and that you get you can go from
organized motion to disorganize that's
the natural way to go you can't go from
disorganized motion and suddenly
spontaneously produced organized motion
and so a very common statement of the
second row of thermodynamics is the
impossibility of Perpetual Motion and so
you could imagine that you take all this
heat all this random motion there and
suddenly that heat you'd find some way
to make that heat all sort of line up
all of that energy that's associated
with heat line it all up and move your
uh your lever from here to there
and but the statement of the second law
is that doesn't happen a perpetual
motion machine so-called of the second
kind because it's associated with kind
of lining up heat and perpetual motion
machine of the first kind is one that
just sort of gets energy from nowhere
but this is getting energy from heat to
make systematic motion so one statement
of the second law is perpetual motion
machine of the second kind is impossible
another statement of of the second law
is heat doesn't spontaneously flow from
a colder body to a hotter one so in
other words you've got all these
molecules running around and in a colder
body there's less running around going
on and it isn't the case that that all
that running around is sort of coherent
enough that it can organize itself to
just go and and put itself into this
into this hotter body that's another
statement of the second law of
thermodynamics
but the the fundamental statement is
that sort of organized motion tends to
degrade to disorganized motion
okay so that's the basic idea and people
had kind of started talking about that
idea in the 1820s and people sort of
assumed oh we all know you can't have
perpetual motion we all know heat tends
to disagree you all know emotion tends
to dissipate into into heat
so that became kind of a thing which
people said well of course we know that
so we'll assume that when we build a
bigger theory about the efficiency of
steam engines or whatever else on top of
that
very quickly people started saying oh
that's a fundamental law of Nature and
then and this is where it got really
confusing they said and we're going to
prove that law of nature from the
features of mechanics so they're going
to say we're going to prove that if you
have a bunch of molecules that say
they're hard spheres bouncing around
then it will inevitably be the case that
large-scale motion degrades into heat
and you never get it back
okay so that was kind of the the state
of things now now uh James Clark Maxwell
for example in the uh
1860s I think
um
already made the point that well
actually you know is this really right
because yes you say you can't get heat
to sort of organize itself to make
um to make kind of coherent motion but
what if you had a little critter it
became called Maxwell's demon that would
be at a scale of molecules and that was
uh you know in a version of it that I
think was due to Kelvin he talked about
that the Little Critter could have a
little tiny cricket bats
um that's a British thing I suppose uh
but but you know it could it could be uh
be bashing these molecules around one by
one and it could say that little demon
could be there on a molecule molecular
scale just so saying okay this molecule
use its energy in this direction this
molecule I want it to collide this way
this way this way and pretty soon
everything's lined up and that thing
that you thought was random motion
suddenly will be organized by the demon
into be some kind of coherent motion why
isn't that possible that was one
confusion another confusion
was the following thing so this chat
clausius that I mentioned Rudolph
clausius
um invented this concept of entropy
and so
what his idea was he invented it at a
time when the idea of energy was still
just forming
but his idea was what
would be the attributes you would need
to describe what kinds of processes
happen in the world and what don't so
for example one kind of process that
happened that can potentially happen is
one that conserves energy a process that
doesn't conserve energy just can't
happen you can't create energy destroy
energy it energy is a constant and so
what he was trying to invent was
something which would describe other
kinds of things associated with the
second law as something where you could
just say well there's this quantity and
you can characterize what can happen and
what can't in terms of this quantity so
what he invented was the following
quantity so he said let's take the total
amount of heat total energy and heat in
something and divide it by the
temperature of the thing and that
quantity and particularly as we make
changes to the the thing we're dealing
with there'll be a change in the heat
content DQ the change in the heat
content divided by T the temperature he
said that's a thing and he called it in
kind of imitation of the word energy he
called it entropy and his it meant kind
of a a um uh something where one was he
wanted those words to be kind of
analogous and he imagined that there
will be laws that uh for energy as he
summarized uh you know the energy of the
universe is constant the entropy of the
universe always increases with what he
said and his entropy increases was kind
of a way of giving a sort of summary of
this phenomenon of this kind of
irreversible change of heat into uh
change of energy into into heat
um and the the way that that you know DQ
over T Works is
um that that will change if if you end
up with um
uh uh your
as as you put your energy into something
which is uh corresponds to heat and
increases temperature
if you sort of do the math you'll find
out that that implies that that quantity
always increases
okay so that was kind of one version of
of this idea of entropy just came from
looking at heat and temperature and came
from asking the question
um what is uh sort of heat divided by
temperature
and
by the way
in
the way we can think about that is
uh they have all these molecules running
around
and it turns out that the average energy
of a molecule is pretty much by
definition well actually the average
kinetic energy of a molecule is some
constant Factor that's a little bit
detailed that depends on monatomic
diatomic molecules or kinds of other
things about different kinds of motion
that they can have but roughly if it's
just one little little spherical thing
it's um the average kinetic energy is a
half times KT where T is the temperature
in K as I think called Boltzmann's
constant
um that's just a constant of nature so
to speak and so it's it's just really
just converting units between the units
of temperature and the units of energy
and so that says that that associated
with any given molecule when it's uh
when when sort of the thing has
developed into just thermal equilibrium
when after you know you might start off
from grinding the cannonballs you know
the cannon hole thing and then it's uh
you know it's grinding it's very
systematic motion of all those atoms and
then they start randomizing when it's
fully randomized then there's this
result that says that the connect the
average kinetic energy is a half KT and
so essentially by saying let's look at
the heat divided by the temperature
you're essentially just counting the
number of molecules in some sense that
are involved or that are that are
participating in this kind of uh sort of
uh this this
um arrangement of energy this
equipartition of entry across all those
different molecules so anyway that's one
definition of entropy there's a
completely different definition of
entropy which people sort of say oh
these things are equivalent well it's
been 150 years and their equivalence is
kind of complicated
um but
the other definition of entropy
um is something which at first seems
quite different
it says imagine that you have
this system and you have all these
molecules and you can arrange the
molecules in lots of different ways
imagine that you just have some discrete
system where you can have either let's
say you can have a molecule a particular
position or at a different position it's
all a discrete grid so just picking
where the molecules go on this grid well
you can count up how many possible
configurations there are for example
let's say that there's a just a a line
of positions and in each position you
either can have a molecule or not
then let's say you have two positions
and each one either has a molecule or
doesn't that means there are four
possibilities either none none molecule
nothing nothing molecule or molecule
molecule and if you have n positions on
the line
with that setup you will have 2 to the n
possible configurations so generally the
number of configurations will increase
exponentially with the size of the of
the system
so the the idea this other definition of
entropy says entropy is equal to the
same constant K this Boltzmann's
constant thing times the log of the
number of possible states of the system
so the log so if you have 2 to the N the
log is what's the exponent so it's n and
if it's logical base 2 it's n in that
case it's a kind of the log is asking
kind of the what's the exponent question
so
what it's saying is the entropy is
proportional to the is essentially
telling you it's proportional to in the
case of the to the N it's saying there
are n positions on this line so that
entropy will be both k thing times n
because the number of positions is two
to the number of possible possible
configurations with 2 to the n and that
means that it's log is n which happens
to also be the number of possible
positions on this line
so then this other definition of entropy
is basically always asking you know
certain things at a macroscopic level
about this system that you have you know
all the gases in this corner of the Box
you know that the overall uh the overall
pressure of the system is this you know
some large-scale effect
some large-scale facts and now you have
to ask the question how many possible
microscopic configurations molecules are
consistent with that large-scale fact
you know
if you know that number of
configurations then you take the
logarithm of it multiply by K you get
the entropy that's this other definition
of entropy entropy in that case is the
log of the number of configurations
consistent with whatever large scale
constraints you have
now
the big question is are these
definitions of entropy equivalent well
people still argue about that it's known
in certain very simple cases that they
are equivalent uh knowing it in more
generality is really hard
um I'm not sure how important that
particular question is because a lot of
the time one is operating in situations
where one's really only interested in
very close to equilibrium very close to
all the molecules sort of equally
sharing in the in this energy thing and
so on and a lot of chemistry and so on
one's using this clausiest definition of
DQ over t for entropy and it all works
just fine the the other definition the
boltzmann definition over the K log
Omega thing the the um uh the the
counting the number of states thing
um is a more sort of pure definition of
entropy in many ways used for other
purposes and sort of the as a practical
matter you can kind of say Well they're
equivalent for the cases we care about
in chemistry and things like this
but the thing that's perhaps of more
interest is the the sort of the big
statement of the second order
thermodynamics is entropy tends to
increase what does that mean that means
if you have certain macroscopic in the
in the boltzmann definition if you have
a certain macroscopic constraints on a
system it will tend to be the case that
the uh that those that you the the
you won't tend to preserve any sort of
specialness in which configurations
microscopic configurations you had so
for example let's say you have the
constraint the gases in this box
okay but at the beginning the gas is all
in the corner of the box and you could
know that macroscopically the gas is all
work out the entropy associated with the
gas being just in that corner which is
much less than the entropy associated
with gas being in in the whole box
because there are many fewer
configurations of where the gas
molecules can be if they're all in that
corner
and so the idea of entropy increase is
the idea that things tend to get more
random in the sense that even though at
the beginning you could say oh yeah I
can see all the gases in the corner of
the box after a while the gas molecules
are sort of randomly arranged in the box
and all you can say is they're in the
box they're somewhere in the box and so
the sort of more general definition the
more general idea of the second law is
that things tend to get more random what
starts orderly tends to become more
random and that's a very general idea
and it's an idea which in its original
form and for a long time was an idea
that was all tied up with temperature
and energy and molecules and all this
kind of thing but that's um not uh uh
that that's not something where um sorry
the um
uh
um
that's the the essence of the second law
does not have to do with
um temperature and energy and things
like that the essence of the second door
is this very much more sort of
computationally oriented statement that
things that were originally orderly tend
to get more random what does it mean to
be more orderly more random what it
means to say that it looks that's more
random is that we can't notice a pattern
in it we can't say oh by the way you
don't have to say where all those
molecules went there's just a rule that
says all the molecules have a lined up
in exactly this way we can State a very
compressed version of a description of
the system without having to give all of
its details and that's kind of an
operational definition of what it means
to be random is that you can't do that
you can't compress things you can't say
I know what's going to come next I don't
have to explicitly write it down I just
have some accurate model for what's
coming next I don't have to explicitly
work it out and so this this idea is
that the sort of the the general notion
of the second law is that what starts as
something that can be very orderly where
you can describe you can compress it
let's say you've got the particles in
the box and they're all lined up in a
nice way in the center of the box and
it's easy to say there's ten thousand
particles and they're all lined up one
after the other in the center of the box
but then after a while they're sort of
all arranged different places around the
box and it's very hard to see where they
all are there doesn't seem to be any
better way to say it than just say this
molecules here this one's here this
one's here and so on there's no
compressed description
so this the more general statement of
the second law is this tendency to go
from orderly things to disordered things
and that's kind of a a that's that's a
vast generalization of the second law as
many many implications for many
different things whether it's for
fundamental physics whether it's for
lots of things in in lots of areas even
in mathematics this idea of that which
starts orderly will tend to become more
disordered and more random tend to
whatever you could initially sort of put
in your conceptual box of I've got the
simple description we'll Escape it and
we'll no longer seem simple like that
now one of the kind of gotchas of
traditional thermodynamics is the laws
of mechanics are reversible that means
that if you've got a movie and you have
this movie and it's got two balls
colliding and then they go out a
different way
they'll go in they'll come out you could
reverse that movie and it's same
perfectly valid movie you couldn't
really say which one is the one that
really happened the one where the balls
came in this way and went out that way
or the worm where the balls came in that
way and went out that way it's the the
laws of mechanics at a microscopic level
are exactly reversible small footnote
there's this thing called time reversal
violation which is something that
happens in particle physics
um that has is not relevant to what I'm
talking about now it's a slightly
different different uh setup for things
this idea that a process that there's a
unique forward whatever when there's a
there's a way to figure out what will
happen from from the configuration you
have now there's a unique way to move
forward from what you have in the future
there's a unique way to move back that's
not always the case let's imagine that
you had something where you had all
these ball bearings or something you
were throwing them in a pit and they had
a funnel and the funnel made them all
come to a single point
well then all those different
configurations are where the ball
bearings weren't in they'd all wind up
going to that point in the middle they
they and so that's an irreversible
process because they all at the end
they're all stopped and they're placed
in the middle and you couldn't go
backwards there's no unique way to go
backwards and say oh I know because they
all end up in this configuration I know
that they were originally in this
configuration here but the laws of
mechanics seem to be perfectly
reversible in the sense that you can
always there's always a unique way to go
back just as there's a unique way to go
forwards
okay so that's a little odd because it
means we're claiming entropy tends to
increase with time but how can that be
because in the end the the what's
happening is just a bunch of molecules
bouncing around and their mechanics is
perfectly reversible so how can it be
the case that entropy is irreversibly
increasing even though at a microscopic
level the molecules are are um
uh are obeying this reversibility
principle for mechanics it's kind of the
famous case is uh you know can you uh
you can sort of scramble an egg you can
smash an object but things don't
spontaneously unscramble spontaneously
unsmash you readily see the thing sort
of going from order to disorder but not
from disorder to order
and that's that's the um and so that's a
little weird there's this kind of
conflict between the microscopic
reversibility and the macroscopic
irreversibility but that's what the
second law is talking about it says on a
macroscopic scale things will tend to be
irreversible even though the microscopic
Dynamics is reversible okay so how does
this work well what happens is this
you have this configuration which is
very orderly and as you run it forwards
in time it will become disorderly
if you run it backwards in time we'll
also become disorderly so you might have
this configuration where everything is
perfectly ordered
the rules and mechanics are reversible
so you run it forwards in time it
becomes disordered you run it backwards
in time it rules the mechanics are
reversible so the same thing's got to
happen becomes disordered
so now what you're reduced to is the
question of why is it the case that the
actual things we look at are things that
seem ordered to us and they become more
disordered rather than there was this
thing that looked to us completely
disordered but it was arranged in just
the right way to spontaneously assemble
itself to get this orderly thing if that
happened there's nothing wrong according
to the laws of mechanics with having
something which was set up so that yes
it was exactly the right thing but it's
all its disorder exactly right arranged
exactly the right way so that 10 seconds
from now it will assemble itself
spontaneously to this very orderly state
and and we'll say gosh that's really
weird you know I didn't expect that to
happen
okay so why is it the case that we don't
have these kinds of configurations that
that um uh were disordered at the
beginning and which spontaneously
ordered themselves
well because the the real story of
what's going on is that and this is what
I've been figuring out and writing about
recently is that the this phenomenon of
going from order to disorder and so on
it's all associated with computational
irreducibility it's all associated with
the fact that even though you know the
microscopic Rules by which things
operate you can't figure out what's
going to happen from those microscopic
rules much more efficiently than
basically just by running those rules
and seeing what happens and this fact
that you can't figure out what's going
to happen more efficiently is why you
can't just say oh it's going to be this
very ordered thing that comes out
because if you could say it's going to
be this very ordered thing that comes
out then you're going to be able to just
say that and not have to go through the
sole irreversible process
so in a sense if you could say there's
going to be order coming out rather than
disorder coming out you could break
computational reducibility
and the fact is that what happens is the
things that we look at the things that
we humans as observers uh who just
observe sort of aggregate effects of
molecules we're not tracing individual
molecules we're not able to see the
whole Dance of the molecules and so on
at our scale and with our computation
abilities we are just looking at uh
we're not able to kind of look into that
computationally reducible process so it
looks to us we just have to say oh we
don't know what happened it just looks
random to us in principle we could drill
all the way into that computational
irreducible process we'd say oh I know
what happened you know this computation
happened that computation happened that
computation happens but we as a
computationally bounded observers just
don't get to do that so we just have to
throw up our hands and say looks random
to us and that's what's happening in the
second row of thermodynamics is that is
this contrast between us as
computationally bounded observers and
the microscopic sort of computational
irreducibility that's being generated in
the system the cause of the second law
is that we are computationally bounded
observers attempting to observe
computationally irreducible processes
and the reason that we don't get to
prepare that sort of Miracle uh you know
disordered initial condition that's
going to become spontaneously ordered is
for the same reason to be able to
prepare it we have to do all this
computation to figure out exactly how
it's going to be set up and that
computation is beyond what we as
computationally bounded observers can
muster and so again the the the cause of
the second law is this conflict between
us as computationally bounded observers
and the computational irreducibility of
mechanics and lots of other kinds of
things it's not that mechanics is
irreversible and predict you know is is
fundamentally not computable it's just
that it takes a lot of computational
effort to predict what will happen an
irreducible amount of computational
effort to predict what will happen and
because we can't provide that that much
computation we just have to say it looks
random to us and that's why the second
law works
when it does work second law doesn't
always work you know people had come to
the conclusion that it was very weird
history because people had sort of said
we empirically think the second law is
valid and then suddenly they and then we
said and then people tried for a long
time to derive the second law from
mechanics and they failed this simply
could not derive it from mechanics
I think we now know I sort of I first
figured this out more or less in the
1980s but just cleaned it up now
um that uh
um it is it is not derivable purely from
mechanics you need one other fact you
need the fact that we are observers like
us
we are observers with certain attributes
of computational boundedness and things
like this
once you have that then you can derive
the second law for observers like us if
you imagine that we were Maxwell's
demons or we imagine with some future
observers with much better censoring
devices and so on the second law will
not be true anymore the second law is
only true for observers like us who have
this kind of computational boundedness
and so on
hello again well technical glitch there
um we were just at the the dramatic
punch line here of talking about the
second world of thermodynamics and why
it's true and this this kind of conflict
between computational irreducibility and
our computational boundedness as
observers and I was was kind of saying
that that's that's in the end what leads
to the second law it's that that
microscopic processes are
computationally irreducible
and our only ability to kind of see
what's going on is through computational
through this computationally bounded
lens as us of us as observers and as I
say in the future we can imagine that
there will be more precise molecular way
ways to measure detailed molecular
motions and this and that and the other
and will no longer be as excited about
the second law of Thermodynamics because
we'll be saying no we don't just want to
know the pressure and and temperature of
a gas we can know this huge you know
petabyte of data about the gas every
microsecond and that in there we have
much more detail and it isn't we're not
that interested in this just pure you
know pressure and temperature type type
information
now you know having said this the second
law people came to the conclusion that
the second law is absolutely always true
they had a few exceptions to do with
living systems that were originally for
reasons of kind of um uh various kind of
religious belief structures that didn't
want to have the idea that um uh that
sort of uh that that life had this kind
of pure decaying process associated with
it and so on but that then became kind
of a thing that sort of enmeshed itself
with the kind of Science of biology and
so on and people were still like well
there are probably some exceptions to
the second law maybe gravity was an
exception of the second law maybe living
systems are an exception of the second
law but people had this idea that the
second law was a mathematically proved
thing in general which it never was it
was never provable because as we now see
it has an assumption about observers
like us that's an absolutely critical
assumption that you can't he can't get
around and although you can kind of say
well we can think about this as just
sort of macroscopic this on the other
you actually have to have that sort of a
piece of your axiomatic framework is to
say its observers like us
so in any case the the thing that um
uh that one realizes in the end is well
the second law is is often true but
there are cases where it might not be
true and there are kind of situations in
which the microscopic Dynamics
is not sort of uniformly computationally
irreducible it has kind of slices of
reducibility all over it and one
particular case of that is what I've
been starting to call the mechanoidal
phase of matter you know when you have a
solid liquid liquid or a gas you just
got molecules bouncing randomly around
and there's no real order it seems and a
gas typically to how those molecules
bounce around but you can have a thing
where there is a lot of detail a lot of
complexity in how sort of the the system
is arranged but yet there is still order
to it and it kind of looks like a bunch
of machines operating it's kind of very
uh you know very machine-like phase and
this is what I call the mechanoidal
phase and one can find it a lot of
computational systems and the things I
call class 4 systems and so on
um and I have a suspicion that a lot of
biology is really associated with the
mechanoidal phase
um and that's really when we say what is
biological tissue is it solid is it
liquid is it gas well it's kind of a
mixture of those things but really it's
a bunch of molecules being transported
around in these very machine-like ways
and it's really like this mechanoidal
phase so anyway that's a little bit of
the story of the second law I I would
say one thing about the second law is
now that one's understood that it is
this conflict between computational
irreducibility computational boundedness
and observers it has kind of a much
broader that has much broader
implications and in fact the phenomenon
that leads to the second law turns out
to be the very same phenomenon that
leads to essentially the structure of
space-time and the way quantum mechanics
works and that's a very remarkable thing
as far as I'm concerned you know in the
20th century the big sort of excitements
of physics there were three big theories
of physics
the theory of gravity general relativity
theory of quantum mechanics and
statistical mechanics the theory of of
things like the second row of
thermodynamics and the Really remarkable
fact that seems to have emerged from our
physics project and this work on the
second law is all three of those
theories all three big theories of 20th
century physics are the same Theory they
all come from this this uh this sort of
interaction between irreduced
computational irreducibility underneath
and computational boundedness of
observers I think that's pretty neat
that these three theories that seem so
different in their in their applications
and in their structure actually are all
the same Theory at some level
and what one can apply then ideas from
thermodynamics that have come from sort
of studying things like steam engines
and so on one can apply them in cases in
space-time in probably in case of
quantum mechanics as well that's a very
fertile area more to be explored in that
area but in any case that that's some uh
that's um uh that's the basic um basic
story there
um and I need to um uh
I need to go and actually see if I can
if we can get out this uh whole
description of this ideas about
thermodynamics
um and uh
um yes stay tuned it should get posted
real soon hopefully if there's nothing
more wrong
um it should be should be able to post
it
um and you can read hopefully a um a
more coherent description of what I've
been talking about about second of
thermodynamics that I've been writing
over the last last few months so
um I should probably stop here and go
off and try and do that as other as well
as other things so thanks for joining me
sorry for these various glitches and so
on and uh look forward to chatting with
you again another time
all right bye for now